c'est dans un hôtel de luxe de doha que
les pourparlers ont commencé c'est celui
là même qui avait accueilli en février
dernier la signature de l'accord
historique entre washington et les
talibans
entérinant le retrait militaire
américain nous sommes venus pour
parvenir à une paix digne et durable
ils sont venus ici avec bonne volonté et
bonnes intentions afin d'arrêter les
quarante ans d'effusion de sang et
parvenir à une paix durable dans tout le
pays
and last thing pis processus de
négociation que d'avoir des problèmes
mais les pourparlers doivent aller de
l'avant avec beaucoup de patience avec
beaucoup d'attention et une réflexion et
ils devraient être poursuivis avec ce
genre d'attention des négociations
retardée de six mois en raison de
désaccord profond sur un échange de
prisonniers et les premières discussions
se sont bien déroulées selon l'émissaire
américain pour la paix en afghanistan
je pense que les choses se déroule
relativement bien et nous sommes
certainement prudent les délégations
afghane se sont rencontrés elles ont
nommé un comité de chaque côté et elles
se réuniront à nouveau pour élaborer une
feuille de route pour leur travail
les talibans ne reconnaissent pas le
gouvernement de kaboul qu'ils qualifient
de marionnette de washington et veulent
un pays régi par un système islamique où
la loi serait dicté par un islam
rigoriste le gouvernement afghan lui
insiste pour maintenir la jeune
république et sa constitution
qui a consacré de nombreux droits
notamment pour les femmes
grande perdante d'un retour possible aux
pratiques en vigueur sous le joug des
talibans
beaucoup d'afghans cren d'ailleurs leur
retour au pouvoir partielle ou totale
toute guerre se termine par la paix il
ne fait aucun doute que la guerre en
afghanistan se terminera aussi par la
paix bien que je ne sois pas optimistes
quant à la fin de la paix en afghanistan
je ne vois pas que les talibans
obtiendront le pouvoir car cette aide
sous condition imposée par le
gouvernement afghan et la communauté
internationale dès le départ on pourrait
faire partie du gouvernement en ayant
quelques ministères ou ambassades
ils ne peuvent pas être un parti
décisionnel dans son ensemble des
négociations qui s'annoncent longues et
ardues
afin de mettre un terme à près de 20 ans
de conflit qui ont tué des dizaines de
milliers de personnes et poussé des
millions d'autres à fuir